sur ma dernière vidéo la barre des 10
lac était plus grande que d'habitude
puisqu'elle était grande à peu près
comme ça depuis quelques temps il ya de
plus en plus de personnes qui trouvent
que je faisais finit pas et c'est
l'heure des explications
premièrement les jeunes ya pas mal de
personnes qui pensent que pour trouver
des jeux je fais comme ça king angela
probable hier jolie tête de chien
c'est quoi la jazz punk si je le fais en
réalité les jeux sur lesquels je fais
des vidéos sont des jeux que j'ai
trouvée soit sur une gamme john qui est
un site qui répertorie plein de jeux
indépendants soit sur tim green light
qui est en fait un système sur lequel on
vote pour les gens indépendants qu'on
veut voir apparaître sur la plateforme
steam mais dans 80% des cas ce sont des
jeux que vous me conseillez par exemple
par mail sur twitter même sur la page
facebook ou même par message privé
youtube bon je suis pas et je sais très
bien que quand personne ne propose en
même temps de faire des vidéos et sur
skate 3 sur gaspard ou sur des jeux
comme ça c'est que ils ont déjà vu
quelqu'un faire une vidéo là dessus et
généralement ce quelqu'un c'est pew
n'est pas du coup je suis face à un
bruit dit là mais dans ma tête il se
passe un peu ça ne fait surtout pas d
eau sur ce jeu vidéo sur ce jeu
n'écoute pas si tu dises à des tas de
personnes m'ont dit tu fais julie baille
le ciel ait beaucoup d'autres personnes
et johnny tu veux pas de prix mais s'il
a déjà fait une vidéo tu sais trop tard
pour toi 3e cas n'a été fait que je
n'appartiens pas au profil youtube
heures qui fait une vidéo dessus alors
vas-y clés en main de la dans 50% des
cas je me prive de faire une vidéo sur
le jeu en question comme par exemple
très récemment avec jazz punk alors j'ai
lu par tous que c'était un jeu vraiment
délirant amusant what the fuck donc doit
bien donné raison à l'un des deux a
raison faut pas que je fasse des vidéos
sur ce jeu et dans 50% des cas je fais
quand même une vidéo dessus parce que le
jeu a l'air vraiment marrant que vous
vous lavez conseiller en main c'est que
je n'ai pas découvert en allant piocher
des jeux sur la chaîne depuis dubaï est
la raison le jeu a l'air plutôt cool
c'est les abonnés qui m'ont conseillé
allait hélas ceux qui trouvent que je
plais jpy dubaï vous allez dire non mais
attends tu te fous nous lie alors jeux
indépendants qui existait depuis pas il
n'a pas fait et vous avez carrément
raison ou plutôt qu'à moitié
effectivement sur la tonne de jeux
indépendants qui sort chaque année y en
a bien 80 % qui sont pas forcément tu
adéquates pour faire des vidéos dessus
parce qu'il correspond pas trop au thème
de ma chaîne le thème de ma chaîne étant
même que la chaîne depuis dubai et que
d'ailleurs des tas d'autres à savoir le
fun et les jeux vidéos on risque tout
simplement d'être fortement intéressé
par les mêmes types de jeu voilà du coup
quand nouveau jus indépendants - de fuck
ou d'europe sort il ya 99% de chances
pour que tu dis pas ils sortent une
vidéo dessus avant moi parce qu'il fait
sept à quatorze heures par semaine et
que j'en fais que trois voilà voilà
ou alors je passe mes journées à guetter
la sortie de nouveaux jeux et rigolait
pas parce que je les ai déjà fait
nouveau joints des disponible sur steam
c'est parti
non je bave de plaisir tous deux se
retrouvent sur wii
y aller plus vite elle avait tout a dit
cette nouvelle vidéo depuis dubaï sur le
jeu freedom of le pig ou alors j'attends
de moi après qu'il ait fait une vidéo
sur un jeu qui m'intéresse pour que je
puisse moi même faire une vidéo sur ce
jeu étant donné que j'ai remarqué que
c'est à partir de ce délai la que les
gens ne lui approprient plus le jeu ils
ne disent plus que tu le pelage y voilà
et du coup en attendant c'est un de moi
je pensais que je pourrais me créer
moi-même mais je vois là ce qui
donnerait des trucs comme ça
bientôt une sécurisation se retrouvent
sur flatterie choisir vos je trouve que
j'ai créée à l'essai on joue sa partie
sa caisse pourquoi ça aussi j'ai même vu
des gens qui allaient jusqu'à dire que
je copiais les titres et les miniatures
des vidéos de tous dit pas et alors
qu'en fait j'ai vu des youtuber en
espagne faire ça et même en allemagne
mais bon je comprenais rien mais en fait
c'est un truc qui se fait de plus en
plus et même en france d'ailleurs j'ai
vu qu'il ya pas mal de newburgh à me
kiejman à faire ça voilà le but d'une
miniature c'est va tirer et vu que je
veux mais vachement en avant irl dans
les vidéos eh ben je me mets sur les
miniatures d'ailleurs ça va peut-être
commencer un choix vous saoule et pour
ce qui est des titres en jeu ce que je
fais ça ya déjà pas mal de temps et en
fait j'avais fait j'avais commencé à
faire ça parce que j'avais vu qu aux
etats unis
et je parle pas de pili paille je parle
notamment de ce match et c'est tout leur
petit était tout le temps majuscule et
puis je me suis dit un jour que j'allais
faire aussi enfin bref tout ça pour dire
que le thème de machines youtube est le
même que celui de lâcher des plus bas et
que même des chaînes en espagne en
allemagne alors un nombre de chefs
incalculable aux etats unis c'est tout
simplement jouer à des jeux what the
fuck et d'horreur en ce film en se
mettant vachement en avant hier elle est
en travaillant quand même pas mal au
montage rajoutant des effets et c'est
bien évidemment sur machine tu dis pas
je vais pas le nier maintenant comme je
vous ai dit je vais pas sur la chaîne
depuis dubaï pour lui voler ses jeux lui
voler ses idées et le volet ci lui voler
sa à tel point que maintenant les
moments où je vais sur la scène du pub
de pew depuis dubaï excusez moi c'est
juste pour voir les derniers jeux qu'il
a fait pour
défaire au contraire est justement pas
pour se dire tiens il a fait des jeux
génial je vais dévoiler tous ses jeux
encore une fois je m'excuse auprès de
ceux qui sont sous lé du fait de
regarder deux fois une vidéo sur le même
jeu je comprends que c'est un petit peu
relou et que cela gâche la magie tout
simplement on connaît déjà le jeu on est
spolié donc on n'écoute pas en même
temps que youtube heures on y voit pas
en même temps que lui fins et ça gâche
un peu la magie du truc mais l'a par
exemple ça fait des mois que j'attends
juste part pour pouvoir faire une vidéo
dessus est marié avec vous et bon voila
j'ai vu depuis dubaï avait fait une
vidéo dessus avant moi il est une
exclusivité sur ce jeu voilà maintenant
c'est pas pour autant que je vais me
priver de jeu que j'attends depuis pas
mal de temps et qui a l'air tout
simplement énormissime d'ailleurs
j'espère que ça vous plaira
en tout cas j'espère que vous serez
comprend aussi ou non dans tous les cas
posément à vos questions dans les
commentaires si vous en avez on se
retrouve très bientôt dans une nouvelle
vidéo je vous dis à tout le monde
pis gèle toute manière si tu fais vidéo
pour dire sachez que tu as des cheveux
je te le reprocher tu plage il le dit
pas celle où elle fut si jacques toubon
plagiat ce prix
la chair c'est chaud au le plagiat de
faire des jobs commence